stéphanie fortin et directrice des
affaires publiques de gnl québec kelly
dans nos studios à saguenay bram forte
mon soir lensois monsieur fillion alors
les experts vous disent rien ne garantit
que le gaz exporté viendra remplacer des
énergies plus polluantes le mazout le
charbon ont-ils raison de dire que rien
ne garantit que votre gaz va remplacer
des énergies fossiles
en fait nous ce qui nous a fait réagir
ce matin par rapport à la lettre qui a
été publié les complètement faux de
prétendre que le gaz naturel va venir
remplacer les énergies renouvelables
le gaz naturel c'est vraiment une
énergie de complément aux énergies
renouvelables
pour pallier à l'intermittence et aux
besoins industriels qui sont
actuellement en demande dans les pays
vous savez on ne peut pas parler d'une
transition énergétique il faut parler
des tensions énergétiques et qui sont
propres à chacun des pays et à leurs
économies actuellement un bon nombre de
pays qui se votent des politiques pour
se sortir du charbon d'oise autres vous
l'avait bien dit en introduction et qui
sont qui sont des énergies qui sont
extrêmement émettrices de gaz à effet de
serre on prend bien madame fortin mais
je lui répondis quand même la question
est-ce qu'ils ont raison de dire que
rien ne garantit que votre gaz va
remplacer des énergies fossiles compte
comme le mazout et le charbon
la garantie qu on oui on en a des
garanties parce que ces pays là
actuellement ce vote les politiques pour
se sortir du charbon et comment ils le
font et le font effectivement art en
augmentant la part du renouvelable mais
également en utilisant la part du gaz
naturel liquifié qui vient comme je
voulais dit d'entrée de jeu
en complément et en soutien à
l'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables alors oui on a une
garantie parce que c'est la réalité
géopolitique dans laquelle on se trouve
et le bouquet énergétique actuellement
qui est la réalité
est-ce que vous avez la garantie qu
votre gaz naturel ne va pas remplacer
des énergies plus propres des énergies
renouvelables écoutez il ya des
actuellement et des pays que ce vote des
taxes carbone
justement pour augmenter la part des
renouvelables
alors non notre le gaz naturel ni
rapport en place et du renouvelable
mais pour répondre
en concurrence avec des énergies propres
renouvelables sur les mêmes marchés
internationaux
demain matin vous savez il ya encore six
mille cinq cents chante sa centrale au
charbon et annonce il y en a 500 en
construction en asie demain matin on se
dit on ferme toutes les centrales au
charbon ça prendrait 412 income gnl pour
répondre à la demande
évidemment dans tous les scénarios de de
lagence d'énergie excusez-moi national
de persil agence internationale de
l'énergie
dans tous les scénarios le scénario de
base une scénario de développement
durable via une augmentation des
renouvelables mais il ya également une
grande partie qui appartient au gaz au
gaz naturel
j'ai des experts dans woerth qui le
disent
la place du gaz naturel et là les
experts qu'on entend du condamné ont de
nouveau eu hier le giron du proc et
titulaire de la chaire en économie
écologique
il dit lui que la transition énergétique
doit aller beaucoup plus vite que ça
aujourd'hui évoque 10 ans en fait la
plupart des experts évoquent une urgence
climatique dans la prochaine décennie et
qu'il faut aller au delà des énergies
fossiles justement comme le gaz naturel
se peut-il que le gaz naturel proposent
une transition trop lent dans les faits
a fait la transition énergétique on est
en plein dedans puis nous non plus on la
nie pas là l'urgence climatique vous
savez l'essence même de notre projet
c'est la lutte aux changements
climatiques et la place du renouvelable
est indéniable mais la place du gaz
naturel liquéfié également et il faut
prendre sont un petit peu c'est comme si
on vous demandait de même atteint 2 vous
de perdre du poids l'humanité
actuellement étant est en obésité si on
veut énergétique elle doit perdre du
poids mais on va vous dire demain matin
je n'ai pour perdre du poids
combien de temps que ça va durer cette
réalité là ça durera pas longtemps
mais nous ce qu'on propose c'est une
solution pragmatique on dit quoi
tranquillement tranquillement on n'a
qu'à les gazettes revivre la fois une
livre à la fois c'est de toute façon la
laissant habitudes de vie donc la bonne
énergie à la bonne place ok jérôme
dupras nous disait hier
durée de vie de gnl votre projet là sur
40 50 ans à peu près alors qu'il faut
agir d'ici dix ans est-ce que point d un
danger que votre complexe se retrouve
finalement dans une décennie ou deux en
sous utilisation
pas du tout vous savez notre complexe de
liquéfaction va être alimentés à
l'hydroélectricité ce qui va faire de
notre complexe complexe le moins
polluant et c'est une première dans
l'industrie mais vous allez vous allez
aller chercher du gaz naturel de l'ouest
puis vous allez l'exporter ceci durant
que vous exportez c'est du gaz naturel
tout à fait assez du gaz naturel
mais comme je vous dis notre gnl va être
produit à l'hydroélectricité notre
complexe doit être beaucoup moins
polluant que d'autres complexes
actuellement en activité et qui sont
aussi en compétition avec le projet
d'énergie saguenay il faut regarder les
choses en face ça c'est le projet
énergie ciani ne se fait pas la demande
va être comblé ailleurs dans un si petit
dernier point madame fortin vous parlez
de 6000 emplois
oui or il ya trois je regarde
aujourd'hui statistique canada 3570
postes vacants au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean selon les
dernières données de statistique canada
postes vacants est ce que vos
travailleurs devront venir du texas ou
de l'ouest canadien des travailleurs
dans un secteur spécialisé comme ça ben
tout d'abord faudrait regarder selon les
statistiques de quelle nature sont ces
emplois qui sont pas complets nous ce
que je peux vous dire que j'entendais ce
matin d'ailleurs j'entendais monsieur
duprat votre émission est fière de dire
que notre région est en pénurie
d'emplois qui va falloir faire en sorte
que les gens viennent de l'extérieur
parle pas de l'extérieur
oui c'est sûr qu'il va avoir des
travailleurs peut-être de l'ouest côte
est des états unis mais assurément du
québec des gens des bleus expatriés qui
vont revenir dans la région parce qu'on
va proposer des emplois de qualité
actuelle exaucé de l'ouest canadien
je peux pas vous dire d'où doudou les
gens exactement avons aimé nous ce qu'on
veut c'est évident mais vont revenir
ben oui on l'espère on l'espère beaucoup
mais nous on travaille avec les tables
d'enseignement et sinon les régions
on veut développer une expertise pour
les emplois qu'on aura à combler cette
expertise là elles vont nous appartenait
et ce soit nous après qu'il pourra
exporter cette expertise
merci madame fortin pour cet ancien joie
merci merci